anger on the streets of Cairo the
country is polarized Egyptians have
witnessed extraordinary scenes of the
past week the German chamber of commerce
and industry in Berlin is in daily
contact with its office in Cairo basant
hell me an Egyptian national is in
charge of talking to employees on the
ground what's the situation Imam every
evening they find out their schedule for
the next day what does it depend on the
demonstrations the situation in the area
where the chamber is located the safety
of our staff is of course the top
priority data by though normally the
Chamber's job is to advise German
companies that want to invest in Egypt
but right now the Egyptian staff here
are not sure they want to return home
themselves here's the dilemma I have my
family my friends and the culture and
the language and here I have better
opportunities and better future so it
depends if like everything is still bad
in Egypt it'll be here better so I'm not
sure I'm undecided yet you put the
unwanted manufacturers can no longer run
night shifts because of the curfew one
crisis meeting follows another Poisson
tell me is monitoring the situation and
can't help but feel worried you think
I'm doing I keep thinking about the
people my friends my family things are
bad and targeted but the focus is
supporting German companies already
involved in Egypt no let's see one
cording to our information there are
around 80 German companies that have a
factory or a branch on the ground 20 of
them have their own production
facilities these companies are involved
in very different fields from oil and
gas exploration to the automotive
industry or manufacturing of sanitation
facilities within to ashton on phones on
et I move in the german company Durov
eat is one of them it manufactures
bathroom fixtures production here in
Cairo continues despite the curfew
deps Wendy padukone is even if
production is not running at normal
levels and we can't think about
achieving good economic results right
now it's still important that staff can
come here and have a sense of normalcy
couldn't Orton Jenkin a sense of
normalcy in the face of an uncertain
future